[Música]
aquí en una de las atracciones naturales
más conocidas de finlandia un destino
popular para los turistas rusos suena el
himno de ucrania
[Música]
entendemos a los ucranianos son rawson
algunos rusos no les gustan esta guerra
uno todos los grupos están computing no
todos son
foto los turistas rusos pronto podrían
encontrarse con algo peor una
prohibición general de entrada en europa
el canciller alemán olaf scholz dejó
claro este lunes que no apoya la medida
patatín creo que esta no es la guerra
del pueblo ruso
es la guerra de putin y tenemos que ser
muy claros con ese tema copec se espera
que los estados miembros de la unión
europea discutan la prohibición de visas
en una reunión informal este 31 de
agosto y finlandia es uno de los países
que se han mostrado enérgicamente a
favor
de néstor los rusos de a pie no
comenzaron la guerra pero al mismo
tiempo tenemos que darnos cuenta que
están apoyando la guerra creo que no es
correcto que los ciudadanos rusos puedan
viajar ingresar europa al espacio
schengen ser turistas hacer turismo
mientras rusia está matando a gente en
ucrania está mal vivo en phoenix fue el
presidente ucraniano volodymyr selenski
aseguró el domingo que el apoyo a la
prohibición estaba tomando impulso
autónoma también está dicho debemos
recordar que cuando el mal adquiere
tales proporciones el silencio de la
gente puede considerarse complicidad se
delinea estoy mucho tomo por lo tanto
tiene ciudadanía rusa y estás en
silencio significa que no estás luchando
lo que quiere decir que estás apoyando
sin 23
bruselas prohibió los viajes aéreos
desde rusia después de que moscú
invadiera ucrania pero los rusos aún
pueden viajar por tierra a los países
vecinos de la unión europea y hacia
otros destinos